there's nothing to investigate there
covert got into the nursing homes by
staff
walking into the nursing home anybody
can bring it in
a delivery man brings it in the heating
repairman brings it in
the food service brings it in
dana uh in my political experience uh
democrats attacking cuomo privately is a
full-time sport in new york state
now they're attacking him publicly over
this controversy i'm wondering
if this is a preview of the 2022
democratic gubernatorial primaries in
new york
well i think that he thought he was
going to cruise right into a fourth term
as governor looking at four terms
oh come on now exit stage left
um i think that the democrats realize
that he has become a liability
um there also feel like he has made them
look culpable because
one of the things that you look in this
timeline is that
the governor's office finally responded
to the justice department but didn't
give that same information
to democratic and state lawmakers not
just democrats but the state lawmakers
who were asking for the same information
until last week
so they're mad and i think that they
have a right to be
it would surprise me if cuomo uh
continues to try to run for a fourth
term i think that is dunzo
okay so kennedy we're about one year
into this
pandemic uh and i'm you know i
look at all the attention that cuomo is
getting right now
and i think remember he became a star
with his daily briefings his hands-on
leadership people were contrasting him
to trump
do you think people are delighting in
seeing his star fall
one year in because he was such a
high-profile personality at the start
no i i think they have grown tired of
politicians who are lying to their faces
while they don't have any uh real
avenues for people to somehow help
themselves from the virus
and you know he he drove old people
straight into the grave
and people realize that now and it's not
just republicans who lost family members
it's democrats too
and that's why you see people like ron
kim and the the
state legislature in new york he's a
democrat and he's going after the
governor
because he knows that these policies
resulted
in loss of life for him personally and
for people who live in the state of new
york
and when governor cuomo doesn't respond
and and
certainly doesn't offer an apology it's
just excuse after
excuse day after day it's really
confounding for people and it's
it's gross and i this is a person who
has not only been a politician for a
long time he grew up in
the privileged shadow of his father who
was also
the governor of new york state and for
someone who has known politics so well
and had such a high profile to watch his
political career crater like this
at in real time this fast is pretty
stunning
greg uh you know so we're watching this
and what we know is
that the cuomo administration said oh
they were under pressure because they
thought the trump justice department
wanted the information for political
purposes
but you know i was thinking to myself
exactly what is the charge here
what is the criminal act that cuomo is
guilty of
hmm it's a question a lot of people were
asking when they're chasing trump for
four years um
a mistake can be forgiven especially
with a novel virus
uh even the experts were wrong but what
can't be forgiven is the arrogance and
the
and the ambivalence and the media
coverage that ignored
all of this in favor of lavish praise so
from the start you had the flip it
kind of the flippancy of the governor
who was feeding off all of this
adolation right
so what they're already dead those were
his words then
if you want to talk about the crime you
got the cover-up uh in order to shield
themselves from political fallout so i
would call that probably a
a a crime um i will say that the
along with that though the media
deserves a lot of this blame
for being kind of the pr arm initially
while this was happening
um and they kind of like just assumed
well you have to break a lot of eggs
when you're making an omelet
except this omelet really really sucks
uh
and the one thing i want to bring up
that i forgot about yesterday
the blackboard with the talking points
that went along with his speech
as though we were a bunch of
knuckleheads and even the talking points
some of them were just like asides like
he said he would trust dr zucker
with his mother that was a talking point
on the chalkboard
and i'm like going what what
i can't even say what i was about to say
because then i would be sent home for
a week but what a jerk how's that all
right so
so jesse as we're talking about
democrats attacking democrats attacking
cuomo
uh the name that keeps coming up is
leticia james she's the attorney general
of new york she was the first to reveal
that there had been a cover-up of the
number of deaths at the nursing home
do you think she is running for office
here because people say oh she'd be the
first woman governor of new york
maybe but she was in on it because she
slow walked it and everybody knew what
cuomo
was doing for nearly a year look at the
timeline juan
in march early fauci last year
said the most vulnerable population were
the elderly
a month later cuomo comes out and
mandates
they stuff covet infected patients into
nursing homes
and then he waits until may after covet
is just
scorched through like wildfire into the
nursing homes
to rescind the order hides the numbers
all summer until the feds opened an
investigation
and he didn't want to interfere with his
soaring manufactured
so he obstructed an official
investigation
until and he waited until biden won the
election
then they dropped at the doj the
investigation
and then leticia comes clean with the
numbers and he still doesn't take
any responsibility again it's the
democrats conspiring with the media
to spike scandals for democrats before
an election they did it with hunter
epstein benghazi cuomo the list goes on
and on juan
and i'm going to make an analogy without
permission ah this would be like a
general
going into war horrible battle plan
gets everybody under him killed
and then when all of the grieving family
members ask
what happened to my son he stone walls
for nearly a year
until the facts finally come out and
everyone died from friendly fire
and the general still won't own up to
his terrible battle plan
that's what this is here with andrew
cuomo
thanks jesse coming